I'm glad we had an uber driver that
understands property can't go too far oh
man
feeling depressed if we pull the top
that I think it will be and be a bit of
a miracle because oh I'm so sorry man
it's only one number we're in a rush now
man
we've got another house to see and oh my
goodness 20 minutes cuz I don't even
know what day it is I'm over the moon
sugar
there we go in the boat like I never
thought that I'd hear myself say that
let me see your ID I feel safe you feel
safe this is crazy I don't get there
that's impossible London Bridge is
falling down
this apartment there were constant
sensing hey what's up my name is Samuel
Leeds and you may have seen my financial
freedom challenges where I start all
over again from scratch to build up my
property portfolio I've done this in
America hey Samuel lives here and I'm
attempting to do the financial freedom
challenge in the United States of
America I live in Sheffield
I've been stripped from everything so
I'm starting all over again from scratch
I've been dumped into a random City I'd
done it in Blackpool so here in
Blackpool I can see him and a lot of
people say to me Samuel you'd never be
able to do a normally done deal in
London so I decided very recently to do
an absolutely crazy challenge this is
crazy financial freedom challenge in
London one day no money central London
is gonna come out on Boxing Day at 7
p.m. did it go to plan you'll have to
wait and find out it was a very
interesting day I learned a lot and I
can't wait for you to see exactly what
happened
[Music]